bonjour gilles sacaze merci de répondre
à nos questions ce soir sur arte france
un important dispositif de sécurité donc
déployés autour du palais de justice
quels sont les risques d'attentât autour
de ce procès
oui bonsoir les lévis qui sont ils sont
d'une façon générale toujours aussi fort
dans la mesure où la menace n'a pas
vraiment évolué les comptes tenus si
vous voulez par des mesures de de
sécurité de plus en plus dur mais il est
évident que ces procès n'est pas que
mais c'est vrai que ce genre de procès
sans lourd de symbole est chargée en
symboles et on sait que l'un des moteurs
je dirais ce qui est en tout cas permet
de désigner prioritairement les cible
pour les terroristes c'est le symbole
c'est toujours vrai et c'est vrai
peut-être encore plus pour vaincre le
terrorisme islamiste mais c'est toujours
vrai pour tous les terreaux ils le
doivent bien sûr la menace était très
fort et elle est encore relevé pendant
pendant ce genre de phase de procès la
question de la menace terroriste a
justement elle revient sur le devant de
la scène avec ce procès gerrard harman a
appelé les préfets à la plus grande
vigilance ce quelle forme cette menace
existe t-elle on parle de menaces
endogènes et exogènes
aujourd'hui la menace elle est
essentiellement
endogène effectivement ou quand on sait
que c'est plutôt des gens isolés c'est
plutôt du terrorisme que qu'on appelle
low cost pourquoi parce que nos services
que ce soit en matière de sécurité de
protection ou de renseignement font
quand même le travail maintenant on a
carrément réorienter les moyens de façon
accessible et donc il est évident que
c'est difficile aujourd'hui de mener de
monter une opération pour les islamistes
de monter une opération de grande
envergure mais il faut suivre ce qui se
passe à l'étranger parce que si
effectivement on commence à voir des
bases arrières si je dirais les
islamistes peuvent se répartit culé sur
des bases arrière et qu'on ne s'arrêter
qu'à l'époque donc un afghanistan
wire ou mali etc on peut encore vivre
aujourd'hui un attentat de grande
ampleur aujourd'hui ce qui fait qu'on
est dans la queue dès là que des
attentats je dirais low cost avait au
couteau fait c'est parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya une pression qui est que même
mise qui porte ses fruits bien sûr sûr
sûr ces milieux là
et on a aussi adapté on a adapté on a
dit on à adapter nos forces et oui
ce procès il va également aborder donc
le travail des services de renseignement
français est ce qu'il ya des failles
dans le suivi des individus dangereux et
si oui lesquelles
non ce qui est le cas le plus fier telle
à mon avis efficacement adapté depuis
depuis depuis cissé vague d'attentats
majeurs
c'est plutôt dans l'intervention si vous
voulez c'est à dire qu'on avait avant
faut le dire c'est pas un sujet tabou
des guerres de police qui faisait que
on entrave est un petit peu là la
rapidité l'efficacité de l'intervention
ceci étant exacerbée à l'époque par des
découpages des compétences géographiques
ou thématiques qui venait un peu
accentué tout ça là aujourd'hui tout ça
ça a été corrigé et ça nous aura coûté
cher mais ça aura moins mais ça ça a été
corrigé les unités acquises les
premières disponibles qui arrivent sur
place et compétente interviennent donc
tout ça ça s'est nettement amélioré y
compris d'ailleurs en prévention sur les
gens pensent qu'on prend en compte
aujourd'hui la menace de façon plus
efficace en matière de mise en place des
forces ce qui reste à améliorer c'est
palier si vous voulez aussi son côté
renseignements si vous voulez mais c'est
passé c'est pas vraiment lié en réalité
au service de renseignement eux mêmes et
même si au lieu des moyens
supplémentaires est axée sur le sur
l'islamisme radical sur blessure et les
bienvenus c'est plutôt lié au cadre
légal si vous voulez c'est à dire que
tant qu'on ne pénalisera pas l'idéologie
on y re on pourra pas aller beaucoup
plus loin parce que les services de
renseignement un repaire des individus
mais après qu'est ce qu'on en fait on
peut pas les on ne peut pas les
interpellés ont peuplé les surveiller au
delà de ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
peut pas mettre un policier ou un agent
derrière chaque chose chaque personne
suspecte ou radicaliser donc en gros on
attend on attend le passage à l'acte si
vous voulez donc si on voulait plus
efficace aujourd'hui et je crois qu'il
ya des propositions politiques dans ce
sens et la réponse aujourd'hui toute
façon elle est politique les politiques
ont souvent tendance à se défausser sur
les services de renseignement ou sur nos
forces mais la réalité c'est que c'est
futile à il est aux ordres du politique
est aujourd'hui s'il ya une voie
d'amélioration elle est dans la partie
juridique et dans la partie dans la
pénalisation en gros de l'idéologie vous
dans la lutte contre l'idéologie alors
il n'y a pas que la pénalisation il ya
bien sûr ça et c'est quelque chose de
majeur
mais il ya aussi en parallèle offrir
offrir une alternative culturelle
spirituelle et c'est donc revenir en
gros à nos fondamentaux d'un côté ça
c'est de virer du soft et dans le hard
c'est plutôt de de pénaliser l'idéologie
islamiste jeudi on n'a pas plus de
chance de déradicalisation cela mist
qu'on avait de chances de 2d fasciser à
l'époque les nazis quoi je veux dire
c'est on le voit avec abdeslam là je
veux dire le message il est clair il est
en prison et il renie rien il regrette
rien et il réaffirme ses convictions
merci j'ai le sa case d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en sûreté et ancien agent de la
dgse